bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ali amrane alors première
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
cette reconnaissance de l'état français
elle a tardé à venir mais elle est enfin
acté elle est là quel regard vous portez
sur le discours d' emmanuel macron et
qui a demandé pardon aux harkis et à
leurs descendants
oui bonjour tout d'abord un soulagement
et je vais vous dire en toute honnêteté
une délivrance aussi bien pour les
anciens qui sont encore vivants les deux
et les enfants à mes harkis qui ont vécu
les atrocités des hameaux de forestage
et des cours de transit ou moins
d'élégance chrono et et un grand
soulagement cette annonce qui a été
faite le lundi
20 septembre dernier et on attendait
depuis coloré d'association depuis plus
d'une trentaine à une quarantaine
d'années pour certains artistes cette
loi est un pas historique pour d'autres
et les ambiguïtés un président a déclaré
nous n'allons pas juger de passer qu'en
pensez vous
non on n'est pas là pour juger passer le
prix de la brique à la raison on est là
pour tirer un trait définitivement sur
cette guerre tragique halle pour les
anciens et les enfants qu'ils ont vécu
et qui sont à l'algérie mais sans
oublier le paradoxe ne tue d'événements
clara pas oublier les sorties contre
1000 morts harkis massacrés torturé par
le fln et surtout les conditions
d'accueil dans les camps de transit que
la france a abandonné et a relégué dans
les camps les camps de la honte ni
cooldowns
justement concrètement dans les faits
que peut changer cette loi de
reconnaissance près c'est uniquement
symbolique puisque vous attendait autre
chose justement
non même si elle est symbolique on
attend réparation comme tout comme toute
loi de réparation avec des limitations
des moments où le président a parlé de
depardon et reconnaît la fois de la
france on peut que parler de réparation
comme l'avait fait en 1995 jacques
chirac avec cette loi concernant les
enfants
du vel d'hiv la rafle du vel d'hiv pour
les enfants des déportés il ya eu
réparation il pareil on demande pour les
anciens qui sont encore vivants et les
enfants de la deuxième génération qui
sont allés dans les camps réparation
puisqu'il a créé un préjudice moral et
voir philippe pour certains enfants de
harkis il faut réparer aujourd'hui
justement ce pardon est ce que vous les
attendez depuis depuis longtemps
justement oui tout à fait nos parents
l'attendent depuis 1962 c'est la france
qui les a enrôlé dans l'armée française
à travers les promesses qu'elle a faites
à l'époque et aujourd'hui la réparation
et cette promesse de loi de réparation
des blessures que nous l'attendons
depuis très longtemps à travers cette ce
discours qui de réparation et de l'est
symboliquement aussi de pardon il faut
pas oublier le travail de mémoire que
nous faisons nous les associations au
niveau national dans les lots auprès des
collégiens et des lycéens ne faut pas
oublier cette histoire de la mémoire et
que nous devons transmettre à tous les
collégiens et à tous les lycéens et à
nos petits-enfants c'est l'histoire de
france comment est ce que vous vous
rendez hommage à toutes ces familles
harkis qui ont souffert
aujourd'hui déjà à travers cette journée
nationale d'hommage aux harkis qui a
lieu chaque année le 25 septembre et
ensuite à travers les cérémonies de tout
le monde combattant auquel nous
participons nous les associations et moi
particulièrement j'ai été élu à la ville
de grasse où la sphère militaire et je
tiens beaucoup à ce que les quelques
anciens qui sont encore valides nous
rejoignent régulièrement dans cette
cérémonie et les enfants de harkis
depuis l'an plus voir maintenant les
petits-enfants qui viennent aux
cérémonies parce qu'ils se sont
imprégnés de leur histoire de leurs
grands-parents de grand père surtout
pour venir leur rendre hommage à cette
journée du 25 septembre très importante
justement vous êtes le président je le
disais du collectif des associations de
harkis des alpes maritimes comment est
ce que les membres ont réagi vous
parliez d'un soulagement mais sont-ils
confiant pour l'avenir ou sceptiques
non je suis confiant des moments le prix
loin de la république mais les
déclarations de cela elle est officielle
auprès de tous les médias et auprès de
tous les français de france et de
navarre je crois qu'il peut pas faire il
ne veut plus faire marche arrière
maintenant nous attendons il le loi
avant la fin de son mandat quelques
années déjà et qu'elle soit votée par
tous les députés j'en appelle à tous les
députés
quel que soit leur bord politique et
tous les sénateurs pour faire
l'unanimité je vous dis bien l'unanimité
pour faire voter cette loi et qu'il n'y
ait pas une seule voix qui manquent
puisque l emporte à la communauté
française en général que les trois les
harkis soit reconnue officiellement à
travers une loi justement est-ce que
vous pensez que cette loi elle fera
l'unanimité au sein de la classe
politique française je l'espère malgré
tout ce qu'on a entendu depuis une
semaine différents gouvernements et que
pouvoir malheureusement ils ont fait et
décret de loi avec des loi
d'indemnisation mais je veux rendre
hommage au président macro parce qu'il a
il a eu le courage n'est pas facile il a
eu le courage de tenir sa promesse qu'il
avait faite à toulon en 2017 quand il
était venu il avait parlé de crimes
contre l'humanité mais nous c'est la
france qui nous amenait
qu'ils enrôlé dans l'armée française
c'est pas le gouvernement algérien mais
c'est la france qui doit réparer et nous
personnellement nous sommes très
satisfaits de cette annonce et
maintenant nous attendons mais là ali
amrane je rappelle que vous êtes
président du collectif des associations
de harkis des alpes-maritimes merci
infiniment d'avoir répondu à la question
sur mercury